held up the grocery line because the
card reader couldn't read my Apple watch
elderly man behind me exhales let's move
this along future move along future boy
welcome everyone my name is today we're
reviewing rare insult subreddit also
boners meme it's my birthday
cheers gamers oh man I just found it
subreddit that's so funny - the youtuber
who put an ad in there rain sounds for
sleepy video please eat a rat poison
sandwich damn it's like these ASMR
videos that put mid rolls on them
great you ruined the whole purpose of
your existence congratulations
hey I need a favor from your parents I
want to have a handsome baby
how can my parents help you in that can
you ask them which precision they
freaked in so I can avoid it my fiance
gets back from deployment in two days
how do I get rid of these make loads and
loads of makeup preferably white cover
the face area as well to match the neck
get yourself a red nose to finish the
cover-up that way you can look like a
clown since your relationship is a joke
wait Mariah Carey okay this should be
good Mariah Carey beginning with I don't
want a lot for Christmas and then
revealing she wants you it's such good
good this brings whole new meaning to
the Sun Wow I'll actually enjoy it now
Mark Zuckerberg always looked like a guy
in a zombie movie who's been bitten but
he's trying to keep it a secret from
everyone it's funny because it's so
accurate my god whole new meaning to my
exact Oberg fan I'm so sad that we
scared Mark Zuckerberg out of the
internet' that was such a beautiful time
when he was part of the internet you
know I want him back
suck please come back you can be part of
me and review alright his Facebook stock
will go right up please suck you got my
number just call me any time it'll be
the most beautiful redemption of all
time I often they dream about winning
the Powerball and buying the licensing
rights to friends
to edit out the life tracks then
releasing it back to the public for free
so everyone can finally understand how
unfunny that show actually is I don't
even watch friends I don't even care
yeah I said it I don't even watch
friends there's so many better shows to
watch I agree please don't take babies
into movie theaters I did not pay 30
bucks to listen to your week pull out
game brah
yeah and don't take them to planes
either don't take your babies anywhere I
just thought I don't want to see your
student ki child bro you pay 30 bucks to
go to the cinema day him shout out to my
cousin got his barber license in jail
and up was his own barber shop when he
got out out that's a $30 over from his
eyebrows grated so yet people say my
forehead is big nah nah I mean I don't
mean to dis abut nah unnatural hair
colors in woman are a warning signal to
stay away it's an example at put
semitism yes
the phenomenom of poisonous animals in
nature advertising their toxicity and
lethality
Epis emmett ism is there to warn off
predators not sexual partners if you're
repelled by it it's working now I think
the problem really here is that people
with gross with colored hair are
generally not epic right my professor is
really something I never wore my
seatbelt while driving to school because
I wanted to die before making it to this
class
oh wow what is that website rate my
professor we're talking about this
yesterday about these these type of
professors that failed in what they
wanted to do so they just pick on you
I'm a man there's so many bad professors
Macy Williams it's so true she'll be a
very cute grandma though she'll peek at
an old age I think that's cool who the F
is osseous porn this is why I love post
Malone for shining light on unknown
artists Ozzy Osbourne was
snorting lines of ants with motley crue
before your father was having wet dreams
or by your mother
burl oh my god these Zoomers they don't
know who are the Osborne it you realize
this is like a Boomer post right back in
my day we listen to real music like
ariana grande oh so sorry for truck
drivers they make their living setting
on they're too lazy to have a real job
the next time you go to a store to buy
old you need I think you need to
remember how old I should got there for
you truckers are away from friends and
families with children for a week
sometimes months at a time just so you
can buy that cucumber your wife is kind
of herself with later well thinking of
your neighbor listen I don't mean to
rippln truck drivers but if you if
you're a truck driver and you are young
I'm sorry but you might want to look
into another profession it's all gonna
be that's like the first job that's
gonna get taken over when it's automated
that's like the next big line of work I
mean that doesn't mean you can't be
appreciated of other people's work but
also truck drivers they take up to what
both lanes and I can pass them stay in
your goddamn lane truck drivers who the
Frick are any of these people and who
the Frick are you c-word I just try to
say your name out loud and my furniture
started floating oh that was the best
part about Charlotte sky Shimokawa I'm
notifying all my old boyfriend that I'm
getting married and I'm officially off
the market
I'm sure the pols setting on your
showerhead will be devastated oh this
summer is great I love this bait oh yes
boomer stuff baby boomers did that thing
where you leave a single square of
toilet paper on the roll and pretend
it's not your turn to change it but with
the whole society bra that's so true
that's that's a lot about society here
you go Zoomers god I wish I was a Boomer
just live in a bubble a Boomer bubble
can you imagine
Oh Felix you are a boomer you're 30 now
okay sorry
oh god I'm actually 30 today Jesus no no
I'm not boomer I swore I swear it how do
you do fellow kids guess what I'm good
at imitating mechanic bro yeah what were
you getting at Jesus Christ that Nick
what is happening there stop it I don't
like it who's making Nick and why is he
my new hero mechanic mechanic bruh
that's awesome
I would Loki want that can i buy that I
can do that with my legs nicki manaj
blocked me because I said slapping her
on the ass was sound like when you
closed the micro braids I bet you she
actually did that it's so funny hey
remember when making Nicki Minaj stop
making music I mean either tik-tok looks
exactly like a fake social media app the
main character of a Disney Channel
original movie would get cyber bullied
on yeah that's it that's literally it
your name sounds like what a deaf
lumberjack would shout I love that
that's worth enough up oh god this
subreddit cracks me up man you think it
would be sad for me to record a reddit
video on my birthday but I actually like
this choose your fighter why does it
look like the guy on the right is
wearing someone else's face Jesus Christ
that looks photoshopped on I'll pick him
as my fighter you'll get two characters
he has a second face where he takes up
his face get it we need to stop giving
Sarah killers cool name like the Night
Stalker the Green River Killer we should
remove the mystique make it sound
something less appealing like micropenis
maniac Bobbie [ __ ] the super to be
fair yeah that's a great point we always
glorify this horrible killers all right
I actually agree with that that's deep
man that says a lot about society man
think about it shame it's like the most
powerful tool in the world if we just
really killed everyone that did
something horrible Society would be epic
except I get shamed all the time by
society for saying bad words so I take
it back I think I've seen this
I'm not sure I've never been more proud
of my country team Olympian overslept
lost coat said Frick it on TV and won us
first gold of 2018 overslept that sums
their work ethic of that generation how
many gold medals to you and your cat
have Gonet some cat mins Deborah I don't
know I'm I'm a little bit of a boomer
now so I'm gonna have to go side with
Deborah on this one I don't think it was
the epoch to remember how many feet
there are in a mile you just gotta use
five Tomatoes five tomato sounds like
five to eight oh and there's five to 800
feet in a mile what that's awesome to
remember how many meters that are in the
kilometer
you just remember thousand because
that's the system of measurement if I
drink mathematician rolling dice yes
official Deutschland official Dutch but
we need to get rid of the mile system
and feet system and all the other system
America I'm sorry this is another thing
I will do as president if you vote
beauty pie twenty twenty twenty I'll go
over to America and I'll fix their
system miles pathetic Oh and Yuki as
well dammit
feet stone it weights about a stone cool
yeah there's only one stone in the world
that really helps actually lent a girl
an umbrella yesterday which takes the
total number of girls I made wet this
year 2-1 don't do yourself like that man
come on
well what if it made her wet what if
that act made her wet you're zero bruh
come on don't be such a down there
you're zero bro so my 14 year old
brother responded to my snapchat story
you look like the 27 year old substitute
teacher that doesn't know how to make
the class quiet this model looks like
she's cosplaying every scooby-doo
character at once yep pretty much
maybe that was the intention who knows
about fashion these days Oh YouTube
never change this man looks like if the
year 2003 was a person bra I don't even
know who you are but I'm sorry you can't
have that beard come on
bland boring Jessica if she was spice
she'd be full court room exchange of the
day doctor before you perform the
autopsy did you check for a pulse
witness no attorney did you check for
blood pressure no did you check for
breathing no so then is it possible that
the patient was alive when you began the
autopsy no how can you be sure doctor
because his brain was sitting on my desk
but could the patient have still been
alive nevertheless yes it is possible
that he would have been alive and
practicing law some of these are golden
are you really gonna plug your show like
an ad right in the middle of the vid
shameless yes I am Kyle because it's my
show how the Freak else am I supposed to
tell people about it would you rather
die painted on walls underneath the
tunnel in a secret locations and no one
sees it to avoid annoying you in the
future Cal I'll advertise my show
somewhere you'll never see it like in
the arms of a woman who loves you Jesus
Christ Luis chill I get it Lois I get it
sometimes you just get these dumb
comments and you just want to go off
it's like when I play a game that just
came out and you still get someone
saying Wow
I'm not hating but someone else played
this yesterday I'm like got your hands
on the Galaxy s8 show us the first photo
you took it was a pee-pee pic that's
funny I found my cousin's old school
picture why your cousin looked like he
about to ask Shrek to do the roar he
truly does he truly does not gonna lie
oh god it's just the guy that looks like
yeah yeah there it is bro looks like
Larry the Cucumber from VeggieTales it's
so true I considered this a compliment
fair enough if your girlfriend cheats on
you you need to understand that you like
something that made her cheat so instead
of leaving her for another girl found
out the air in yourself apologize to her
and be a better man we lost the wrong
stark people actually think this blows
in my mind the final buzzer LinkedIn
Chadd champion Chad champion with a
great alter ego I have I have an alter
ego because I whenever I don't want
people to recognize my name when I order
stuff online it's something similar to
Chad champion but I kind of wish I
picked I picked such a champion said you
look like you could turn water into wee
Oh Charlie critical looks like if John
wick came up I'm sure they'd kill the
dog Ben started a keto diet is it
Charlie likes poking out about the keto
diet as well bro that makes it sadder
I'm sorry Charlie there's no recovery
from this YouTube comments are prime I
don't think so but Jimmy Fallon laughs
like he has trained my taste cooking me
spaghetti carbonara because it's my
birthday so when I finished this video
your mom's so lazy she took nine years
to finish the date joke when some random
in the internet is more committed to a
you mama joke than your dad was to your
actual mom Tom looks like Eminem's
younger and lesser-known brother
skittles Oh Tom you probably had to
shave his head for a part or something
it's weird I think Tom could actually
pull off but no he does it I always
thought I should try it you know I
always wanted to try it but I won't look
good I have a weird relationship with my
hair I don't I don't like it that's why
I always wanted to shave it do a buzz
take the bus pill man for whatever
reason does every apartment complex have
a dog weight limit of 20 pounds oh my
god this I can promise you my 90 pound
golden retriever is a hell lot better
behaved than Karen's seven pound piece
of devil-worshiping chihuahua or child
for that matter god it pissed me off me
and mine said we want to travel with our
dogs but there every company has like a
weight limit for your dog oh I'm sorry
you can bring your fat ugly annoying
child that Yeltsin and annoys everyone
while our innocent beautiful little
angels oh it weighs one kilo too much
they can't come on our airplane so why
can't your fastest not be weight and
then tables have turned
he looks like a down but
right all right that's it that's it for
this week's no no no it's every week
it's every day bro rare insults that was
fun I enjoyed the sub rate I hope you
guys did as well there's no point in
saying happy birthday because it's
already happened but if you didn't on my
actual birthday I want you to be ashamed
of yourself and the only way to redeem
yourself it's to smash like on this
video and subscribe and check out to the
figurine I guess we'll promo that thank
you guys see ya bye Mike well you
haven't tried to pursue Malaysian
citizen e after 50 million our troops
fetch down just now it's still relevant
just download it